foreign
Justin Thoreau shows Jennifer Aniston
some love after she reveals her past
struggles to get pregnant and Jen she's
opening up even more admitting she hates
social media and has some issues with
Fame what you resist persists so I'm I
also think you know it's something that
is a part of our world now and it does
it's not going away and how you can
actually kind of have a little bit more
control over the narrative that's out
there
um and right some wrongs and some silly
things that we God knows that are said
often
sounds intriguing the actress made
headlines on Wednesday opening up for
the first time about her fertility
journey in a cover story for Allure
magazine explaining that she tried
everything to get pregnant including IVF
calling it a challenging Road and really
hard making it even more difficult the
public narrative that she only cared
about her career and didn't want
children something Jen says was quote
absolute lies it's unexplainable of
course Jen was married to Brad Pitt from
2000 to 2005. we can do it all we're
sleeping we're 80. and Justin from 2015
to 2017. I got a good one I got a sweet
kind man yeah and after Jen posted some
snaps from the cover story to Instagram
Justin swooped into the comments to show
his support with two simple emojis a
fist bump and a heart
that's a good thing but when it comes to
online platforms Jen says she's not a
fan quite bluntly she says I hate social
media I'm not good at it for this next
portion we're gonna have to put on some
goggles
when Jen joined Instagram back in 2019
she admitted she was reluctant but
finally took the plunge when she got
tired of people telling her to do it oh
and no big deal she gained a million
followers in her first five hours and
today she has 40 million plus if it's
sort of bizarre huh but even with all
those adoring fans Jen says being online
is torture for her and it doesn't come
naturally I mean it just goes against
every single particle in my being and
according to Jen with the rise of social
media also comes a major shift in the
entertainment industry quote I feel like
it's dying there are no more movie Stars
there's no more glamor and she theorizes
that the lack of Technology when her
massively successful sitcom Friends was
on the air may have something to do with
why it's still so popular today quote we
really loved each other and we took care
of each other I don't know why it still
resonates there are no iPhones it's just
people talking to each other you guys
have to go to the new house right away
or do you have some time
we got some time
okay should we get some coffee
sure
where
and all that Echoes what gentle DT last
year ahead of the highly anticipated
Friends reunion there was something that
was laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
Pathways that we instantly it was in our
DNA that we were family we were going to
take care of each other we're the most
grateful women that I know who have been
able to be a part of something like this
foreign
[Music]